okay so a wonderful invention here these
are children's uh light-up
clip-on rollers I've uh I'm attaching
them to the front of my Healy's I'm
going to clip these bad boys in and then
take him for us
spin if you know what I mean while my oh
jeez okay well I could it yeah ignore
the fact that one down and roll downhill
that's what I aim to do I just need to
get into push doing it
Oh God oh my god you got it look 21 so I
guess you're trying a different method
than mark yeah uh oh okay idea I have an
idea okay it worked
yes fingertips look like you scraped up
right okay so my attempt failed
wait I have a very hard ah alright so
there's four wheel Healey mark 4 with
this works go I need to get farther down
the what we look like right now oh oh
I'm working so close huh
oh oh yeah oh ah
are you almost doing a split - they hook
into this really torture methods pull
over I just put them on your butt okay
so we reached the conclusion of our
hypothesis which is that Healy's are
already the pinnacle of skating
technology more wheels only have more
problems Helion groves and how did
what next Kanye Oh